[Music]
well in a few days and you'll see it
here on fox joe biden is going to
formally accept his party's presidential
nomination at the same time
alone in her apartment speaking to the
mirror governor stacy abrams of georgia
will do the very same thing and she
wants to thank you for the unprecedented
level of support she received
she looks forward to running this
country now abrams will not be allowed
to say that from the stage of the dnc
of course party leaders won't let her do
that the whole point of a convention is
to highlight a party's most popular
positions
while keeping its crazies hidden from
public view
but what if suddenly everyone in the
party goes crazy
what if there are no sane people left
well then you get what we're seeing
right now
democrats have spent the last week
outlining a conspiracy so wicked
so brazen and dangerous it makes
russiagate look like jaywalking
according to elected democrats in the
news media they control
the president of the united states is
working to eliminate the u.s mail
now trump isn't closing the post office
that would require an amendment to the
constitution
no it's far worse than that and much
sneakier
trump is stealing the mailboxes driving
through democratic
neighborhoods in the middle of the night
tossing them in the back of a station
wagon cackling like the madman he is
or having his lackeys do it either way
the effect is the same
with no mailboxes democrats won't be
able to vote
donald trump is stealing the election
and here's the thing
democrats can't call to complain about
it it turns out that someone took all
the pay phones too
can you imagine apparently joe biden
read all about this on facebook or some
website whose name you can't remember
but it was all there biden was so upset
he almost snarfed his metamucil
he was still ranting about it during a
virtual fundraiser on friday
as he told the crowd quote they're going
around literally with tractor trailers
picking up
mailboxes you want to go online and
check out what they're doing in oregon
i mean it's bizarre got that
literally with tractor trailers in
oregon
the funny thing is oregon hasn't voted
for a republican in a presidential
election in more than 35 years
and it definitely won't this year
mailboxes are not
so it's unclear what exactly trump might
be gaining from taking oregon's
mailboxes
but whatever it's just wrong former vice
president al gore who increasingly looks
like a wax effigy of himself
went on cnn the other day to make that
point
by tampering with the postal service he
is in effect putting his knee
on the neck of american democracy
stealing mailboxes says al gore is
nothing less than trump putting his
knee on the neck of democracy the blood
is draining from america's face
we are fast losing consciousness as you
can imagine this caught the media's
attention
without pausing to see if it was true
they rushed to their cameras to repeat
it
essential sorting machines removed blue
mailboxes literally
hauled away on flatbed trucks mailboxes
being picked up and stacked up what's
that about
other than voter suppression they're
seeing some of their mailboxes in their
communities uprooted
that's a problem people are worried
about the post office
you're seeing you know the mailbox is
being taken away can we vote
what's going on the removal of
mailboxes uh the removal of equipment
within the postal
offices and the rest is to undermine the
postal service
at a time when the postal services need
it now more than ever
are you listening to this they're
literally hauling away mailboxes on
flatbed trucks
and phil rucker of the washington post
for one is not going to stand for it
phil rucker the washington post thinks
that disappearing mailboxes are a major
problem
his boss nancy pelosi agrees with that
but since pelosi is the speaker of the
house
and not a hacked reporter at jeff
bezos's daily newspaper pelosi can
actually do something about it that's
why she's in charge and not phil rucker
pelosi announced that she's calling back
the congress from summer vacation to
deal with this
pelosi said it is time for a legislative
branch to save democracy from donald
trump whom she announced
is trying to quote sabotage the election
by manipulating the postal service
by the way it's not just the election
trump is also trying to starve old
people whom he hates despite being one
with no postal service police he said
seniors may not be able to get their
social security checks in the mail
ned suppose he's 80 years old so you'd
think she'd know that the government
hasn't used the postal service to send
those checks since 2013.
ah in other words we can now be pretty
sure that nancy pelosi doesn't live on
her social security benefits
or even notice them but don't tell the
rest of the house democrats they are
riled up some have called for the fbi to
investigate the postmaster general lewis
dejoy
and not long after they said that their
militias showed up outside dejoy's house
[Music]
this is a big story so the question is
who is stealing all those mailboxes and
it's actually an interesting tale if you
get into the
details of it consider a recent tweet
from new jersey congresswoman mickey
cheryl who might not be the smartest
member of congress
cheryl posted a photograph yesterday of
a truck filled with mailboxes
the postal service she wrote is being
quote systematically dismantled here in
new jersey and around the country
then a few hours later mickey shell
wrote this quote at least one post
office box has been replaced
we'll continue to provide more
information as we have it hear that
more information as we have it mickey
cheryl is like her own 24-hour news
service
and just like cnn cheryl didn't bother
to check her facts before going on air
by contrast former national security
adviser susan rice did do
some reporting on the subject and we
laud her for that rice checked with
actress mia faro
and actress mia ferro claimed that
mailboxes were being removed to
disenfranchise democratic voters
so susan rice tweeted that susan rice's
tweet was shared by more than
30 000 people a lot of americans saw it
now it was totally false
but it's still up rice is not a
republican so twitter is fine with that
no violation of their terms
as a matter of fact we try to stick to
facts nobody is stealing
america's mailboxes this is another hoax
it's another lie it was totally made up
in order to manipulate you
the post office moves mailboxes as a
matter of course
and has for many years donald trump did
not order this
it is normal a 2017 report from the usps
inspector general for example
notes that the postal service has
removed 14 000 mailboxes over the
preceding five years this has been going
on since at least
2009 and 2009 was the same year by the
way that barack obama who presided over
this horrific mass
mailbox removal delivered the following
assessment
of the u.s mail people say well
how can a private company compete
against the government
if you think about it ups and fedex are
doing just fine
right the uh no they are i mean it's
it's the post office that's always
having problems
wait what did you hear that talk about
an unexpected twist ladies and gentlemen
the great mailbox conspiracy of 2020
turns out to be bigger and more complex
than we realized
barack obama is in on it too don't tell
susan rice
so what is this really about in real
life well last week the president
refused to hand over 3.5 billion dollars
to the postal service in recent stimulus
negotiations
that was money that would go toward
mail-in voting this
is what they're mad about that was a
blow to one of nancy pelosi's top
priorities
democrats favor mail-in voting democrats
favor any form of voting that does not
entail
actual voters going to actual polling
places they refer to this as quote
ballot access like it's a civil rights
issue it is not
a civil rights issue votes cast by mail
are easier to tamper with
the identities of the voters who cast
them are harder to verify
mail-in voting makes voter fraud easier
that's why we haven't had a lot of it
throughout american history and that's
why democrats are for it and we have
seen fraud
there's no mail-in voter fraud that's a
lie just in the past few months for
example a postal worker in west virginia
pleaded guilty to altering mail-in
ballots four men in new jersey stand
accused of fraud after the usps found
hundreds of ballots
in a single mailbox in a local city
council election
in clark county nevada more than 200 000
mail-in votes from the recent primary
election
have been declared undeliverable those
are
local and statewide elections imagine
this
on a national scale during a
presidential election imagine it
magnified
across 50 states what would be the
effect of that
well there would be no way to assure the
integrity
of the presidential election oh right
that's precisely the point in july the
boston globe described how a group of
biden operatives including john podesta
had a secret
war game in which they gamed out the
presidential election
this fall here's how the boston globe
described one scenario in which
podesta took biden's role quote mr
podesta playing mr biden
shocked the organizers by saying he felt
his party wouldn't let him concede
alleging voter suppression he persuaded
the governors of wisconsin
and michigan to send pro-biden electors
to the electoral college
oh not crazy both democratic governors
eventually in the scenario that podesta
outlined at the war games
americans quote stopped looking to the
media for cues
and waited to see what the military
would do
end quote so john podesta is
gaming out how the united states
military can put joe biden in office
and that tells you a lot about how
democrats are thinking about this
election
making up bizarre stories about how
donald trump steals mailboxes
may be ludicrous but stories like that
make america even more paranoid and
fearful than it already is and that's
the point
stories like this prepare voters for the
day that the democrats call in the
generals
to make joe biden president